what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch from our friends
over at new rockstars today the
breakdown and easter egg video
for one division episode four you know
they got the goods
it's a like a it's a it's a wiles of a
video it's a long video let's do it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode four an episode ripped
straight from the headlines of new
rockstars videos
let's just add it that's better there
were
deposited early on run that clip
why sitcoms this is this is the this is
the board new rockstars
that's exactly what we said we watched
it
a ton of details in this episode that
you might have missed
i'm gonna break them all down shot by
shot spoiler warning let's get started
the episode opens with
now one of my favorite mcu sequences a
red opening scene style panic showing
that's the moment
of the blip return one of those snap
victims monica rambo re-materializes
this all occurs simultaneously with
avengers in game the moment hulk
reverses snap and it's pure chaos
we did see a bit of this undusting in
spider-man far from home when a tuba
player got wrecked
[Music]
this time it's just this tragic
re-materialize
comedic effect but listen closely to
these opening seconds
[Music]
did not catch that at all this one
lieutenant trouble in the comics
lieutenant trouble was captain marvel's
nickname for kit renner but in the mcu
it is her nickname for the young monica
rambo but the lines before that suggests
monica's mother maria rambo callsign
photon from captain marvel had to leave
monica behind to be raised by her
grandmother at some point sounds like
there was a space mission
a sword maybe something we will see in
captain marvel 2 or
something that actually led to maria's
cancer later in her life now the
close-up
imagery of monica's particles come the
scrolls gave her cancer
no or maybe we'll see it in secret
invasion
something hinted there perhaps yeah
that's absolutely possible
gloriously rendered dare i say even
better looking than an
infinity war notable difference though
monica's pieces are not desaturated
they're not ashes just like
bits of her this evokes joe quesada is
this whole show is based on among this
chaos we see one guy re-materializing
beside a hospital bed and assuming he
dusted five years earlier he would be a
total stranger
there's another patient reappearing in
the hospital i love it i'm so horrified
that it was just like a peaceful return
on the other side of hulk snap
next sword sentient weapon observation
response division
this is headquartered on a coastal base
that looks a lot like cape canaveral
shuttle launch pads and that big old
hangar it's
massive compare that to the size of the
nearby office building
this could be where sword built pieces
of the peak space station which might be
where
fury was and that part from home post
credits gotcha one video is apparently
set three weeks after end game this
would be around november 2023
and far from home is set in summer 2020
okay so it definitely takes place before
that's base station operational if it
isn't already the lobby is laid out
similarly to shields old triskelion in
dc
i just had a thought hold on a second
hold on really super super quick i'll
make this really fast
you know how they believe mysterio was
from another uh earth
yes like they believed the lie maybe
because the events of wanda vision
already happened with opening up the
other earths in different realms and
stuff
that already happened so that was easier
for them to believe whatever mysterio
was talking about
in far from home maybe yeah maybe he's
just using that to his own advantage yes
exactly marvel the lobby is laid out
similarly to
shields old triskelion in dc sword might
have grown as an
offshoot sister organization under the
leadership of maria rambo throughout the
90s and 2000s while fury was overrunning
shield on the screens news comes from
w-h-i-h
that's the end universe mcu news service
that we saw in promos for ant-man
there's also a spectrum news
spectrum is one of these superhero names
monica rambo takes off it's also my
shitty internet service
i'm gonna say that could be a product
replacement we may be seeing this oh
okay
origin story as a future in the mcu now
monica wears this necklace
looks like a small golden sword pendant
this might be what turns into the
necklace in west view
i think it's this more than the new
lanyard id badge she gets
because it sounds like sword is her home
it's really her last connection to her
mother this pendant represents that and
westview is kind of
expressing that history now with this
sword necklace that she can't separate
herself from and then monica's met by
gotcha director tyler hayward calling it
now
[ __ ] this dude easily could have
activated her id but instead he had her
feel like an outsider so that he could
swoop in as a white knight and escort
her in
he clearly feels threatened by her post
blip return he thought she would never
come back exactly
brad against peter parker he knows the
status he has should belong to her
and now he's apparently throwing her to
this assignment hoping she will get
erased from this like when we were
watching it really early on we're like
jimmy lost someone in federal witness
protection
someone whose past associates claimed
not to know
suddenly and now hayward is throwing his
all-star agent
monica rambo at this i'm beginning to
think hayward could have set
all this up like he might have made a
deal with
me maybe he's really
looking forward whom i think could be
agnes ralph
and hayward did this to raise his status
at sword while helping that kaiser soze
slip through the cracks
to hijack an unstable infinity stone
irradiated avenger
to create a pocket reality where she
could
oh wow that devil figure drains her of
her power
oh so he's suggesting that whoever agnes
is talking about with ralph
could be the witness that jimmy did not
that jimmy lost
oh how fascinating and i would love that
if that guy
that uh hayward is actually the like a
big villain of this
whole season yeah i thought he was gonna
be like some snotty little douchebag
dude he had it yeah i think he would be
the actual villain maybe he could be
mephisto in disguise
and he doesn't know what to do i mean
i'm just saying wayward hayward knows
quite a bit about ancient cosmic
radiation
my equipment registered an extremely
high level of cmbr
that's relic radiation dating back to
the big bang and uh not to go two hecks
crazy on this guy but the diplomas on
his wall are arranged in a ring
i'm just probing a fake town with drones
till something sticks the two catch up
how are the numbers for the astronaut
training program i'm dismal
on the blip and half of those remaining
have lost their nerve
interesting sword test pilots sound like
a possible setup for the fantasies
exactly whom we know are called exactly
hayward says shifted away from manned
missions and refocused on robotics
nanotech ai sentient weapons like it
says on the door
it also says observation and response on
that door
it's not creation what you're telling me
sword was creating
sentient weapons yeah definitely evoke
some notes of
weapon x or some kind of way for the
mutants to drain
full of threats and allies monica's
allies sound like her scroll friends
boom
maybe not everyone will see us allies we
know from far from home things are about
to
skew into a cree scroll war i thought
cree having sleeper cells was top secret
information nick then monica meets jimmy
woo
james e woo fbi nice jimmy does some
close-up magic
a trick that he learned from scotland
exclusive magic class in the hand man
and the wasp
how'd you do it scott do what the car
trick
can you knock now these cops deny
west view even exists but my question is
does east view exist
were these cops from west view their car
warped
their minds brainwashed so that westview
would have no
law enforcement and thus be more
vulnerable to a hostile takeover some
possible
number details here suv is numbered
85-12 maybe for the 1985 12
issue comic book suddenly one division
is based on her drone is numbered as
57 maybe for avengers issue 57 the debut
of the vision and some are pointing out
that too i mean
things like marvel but you know i think
that's also just kind of generic colors
dr darcy lewis returns from the thor
movies now contracted my sword alongside
these others
i think the comic reference lines up
full intelligence artificial
intelligence ai was mentioned as one of
the new sword disciplines hayward
highlighted earlier
shifted away from manned missions and
refocused on robotics
nanotech nanotech is the most ambiguous
sci-fi thing
from what are you getting a colossal
amount of cnn colossal
cmb electromagnetic radiation in the
universe
it does date back to the big bang and
it's actually the same kind of radiation
that creates tv static
thus the staticky border membrane of the
town but the big bang connection is key
because as wong told us an infinity war
that is how we got these
things big banks and six
elemental crystals
[Music]
oh it's so connected remember one of
those powers were activated by one of
those infinity stones a mine stone
and this whole universe just went
through four shock waves of that same
kind of cosmic radiation
which could all be connected to this new
anomaly
i love this i love sewers showing how we
got our beekeeper
wu doesn't like the plan there's no
reason to suspect the perimeter doesn't
extend subterraneously
there's no reason to suspect it does
yeah jimmy wu is saying that the pocket
reality
extends beneath the surface another sign
says
somehow mouth might be coming from below
town perimeter
is the shape of a hexagon confirming our
paranoid suspicion about all the
hexagonal imagery it really may just be
that this whole town
is a hit darcy queues up the sitcom feed
confirming that she was that notetaker
watching at the end of episode one
look i know it's been a crazy few years
on this planet but
he's dead right not flipped
dead i just point this out because that
sword agent behind them is
loving this yes yes with me i would
totally be that guy
so the sword operatives are able to id
the hearts as
todd and sharon davis sharon davis is
actually the name of an art director on
monovision
john collins the name of another our
director on the show actually later the
70s credits say produced by
liam patrick she is a post production
that's usually what these film studios
do he's an actual crew working for
marvel joker
tandon and if you look closely at the
notes on his form avalash expresses
concern for his father and sister this
information was obtained when
vision away
the physical safety of residents is now
in question when vision restores him
avalanche
vision awakened him when did this happen
yeah this is the last episode
it kind of sounds like what vision does
to agnes in trailer footage
am i dead no if this is based on house
of m
vision might be playing a kind of
wolverine role awakening warped person
after warped
within this alternate reality until the
girls come crumbling
dude that's so cool
suggesting she might not be a true west
view victim
but someone hold on we gotta take that
back a tad bit i want to read that
alabash
expresses concern for his father and
sister this information was obtained
when vision
awakened him is wanda controlling
controlling a whole town
physical safety of residents is now in
question when vision releases him
alabash becomes normal again
wow what a clue
is resting there and yeah i mean the
theory lines up totally with
how wolverine in the comic goes around
and helps people remember
the actual reality and not the
fragmented one that wanda has created
but i bet vision doesn't even really
realize what's going on well yeah and
what a conflict that creates both for
him
discovering the layers of truth at work
here but also
what yeah you're maintaining all this
even he's like wait what because
and it might that might make sense would
that seem with herb too
uh in episode three when he's interact
how sometimes when people interact with
him they start breaking the fantasy that
wanda has created usually when vision is
around
ooh i love this i mean like he has
definitely demonstrated a certain amount
of suspicion for their reality like so
much of his dialogue in his solo scenes
and at work and stuff are like what is
this why are we here what are these
forums for like he's clearly probing the
reality too
so it sounds like a lot of saving the
day
probably lies in the hands of vision the
segway how light in the hands of uh
wolverine in the comics
yeah oh how neato i love it i love it
no new jersey id was found for her
suggesting
she might not be a true west view victim
but someone working with the darker
forces to manipulate wanda dottie is
also missing but you know this is still
a work in progress her photo isn't at
all on the wall they might not have
printed out her photo yet but a lot of
people are thinking she might also be a
kind of key to west view
some doors saying she's playing clia now
of course everyone's talking about this
jimmy wu's notes are clearly meta jokes
about the questions we have literally
been asking
this is wild our video titles and
thumbnails have been asking about
hexagons why sitcoms vision alive or not
but there's a lot of details here the
board mentions a five mile radius which
might explain why exterior stuff
outside of west view like those east
view cops and the highway sign
remain warped as well and then under the
possible perpetrators of this
scrolls yes this confirms that jimmy wu
and all these feds know that squirrels
exist now jimmy brings them up as
possible
antagonists which contradicts the
friendly relationship with the squirrels
shared
fascinating fascinating it does sound
like some authorities view parts of the
squirrel race as a threat
they're trying to contact wanda so
you've seen that radio on wanda's
kitchen counter right
the next time she's washing dishes which
by my account happens about
once an episode barf bart little shout
out to stark's hollow projection
i hope he's not part of this but also
once per
episode how many episodes have they seen
based on their footage of monica from
that 60's era there are other lost
episodes so can we see them please i'm
from dartmouth there is opening credits
from episode 2 is totally skipped over
yeah
this happens later with monica's
expulsion so who is
editing this feed i'm thinking it might
just be wander herself
he's in there but still we know he's at
the computer experiences
his cable turns into a jump rope but we
don't see what happens to him when wanda
rewinds
some believe he might have been warped
into that ice cream guy from episode
three but that was a different actor
than zach henry they normally don't like
change their faces i just assumed he
might have been reversed back out
through that sewer tunnel and the aspect
ratio widens as wanda
ejects monica using her red chaos magic
to smash her through the living
room the nursery the outside fence and
the whole west view border
crazy deleted scene from the second one
that literally broke monica through
the fourth wall then in case
that's cool wow even more unsettling
than the gray corpse vision from
infinity war
it's the fact that he just reverts to
normal with a simple cut
back yeah nothing happened and thus can
happen again
any [ __ ] time we cut back to him but
this tells us that the version of
vision that exists in the real world is
as darcy said
dead dead he is a corpse that wanda
could be trying to reanimate with
sorcery so if he has been a corpse the
whole time does that mean that wanda
banged a robot corpse an episode god
damn right you did dead horses
necrophilia
i don't think all these people are being
ragdolled around with just like sit
commie sleeves
over them it's more like once you're in
the bubble all of reality within this
bubble shifts as a whole like your whole
body re-materializes to be whatever
wanda imagines you to be
wherever she wants you to be doing
whatever she wants you to do but yeah
vision is dead folks and i think west
view's hexagonal shape tells us that
my only question about whether or not
he's dead there's promo images of him
trailer footage of him i think breaking
through the thing
that wanda has created he's on the other
side of this
at least in a couple of moments i i i've
seen it was i think it was even in that
sneak peek
that came out recently you know that's
kind of why i'm like well
maybe she did success she does
successfully bring him back yeah
or or maybe whatever animates him is
tied to
her and not so much this dimension
itself or something like that
she can clearly manipulate things going
in and out yeah i would be very curious
to know because these are all real
people ostensibly that she's doing this
stuff with it seems like everything has
a physical counterpart somewhere
i think westview's hexagonal shape tells
us that this
is a town-wide hex spell all to try to
resurrect vision's corpse
using the cosmic radiation from wanda's
infinity stone activated powers
may be further enhanced by the recent
shock waves of the same
kind of cosmic radiation and despite
monica saying
it's all wanda i think jimmy wu's whole
missing person mystery
being the start of all this tells us
that wanda is not doing this alone
at least not magnus and
jimi hendrix says voodoo child plays
over the credits a nod to the true
witchcraft at play here but watch
vision's eyes
in the final seconds he is nervously
looking over at wanda
and then his head lowers but his eye
line raises over the tv
he is looking at us he wants
out follow me on instagram follow the
rockstar subscribe to our channel
youtube for breakdowns of all your
wonderful
see you next week when one division
makes fun of our brand spots for aqua
socks
i gotta pull this back briefly is he
really looking at us
i mean i think it could just be a trick
of the eye line yeah but like looking at
the tv i i can't
tell if his peoples are directly looking
at us because he could his right eye
looks like it's
his his left my right like the camera is
right here for you guys and then the
screen is right here
like it starts right here what we're
watching so if i'm looking like right
here
and my head's down it could look like
i'm looking at the camera
from a distance punching on this
[Laughter]
anywho either way though i mean it's a
fun theory to throw in it
at least him darting his eyes over to
her maybe it's a little bit of nerves at
least
yeah well all right guys that was a hell
of a video
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already be well worth
your time
i can't wait for episode five there's so
much more craziness to
unpack my mind is like i got my that
that
mind [ __ ] on this one to put it
lightly hit that like button
also uh it's the end of the month and i
did want to shout out uh all the people
who are pleasure to looted takes and
behind the scenes worked here where you
get all those
special but you know what i'm trying to
say like i can shout out all those
people
kent mcnoy eva drazdikova tiana h
chase gardner marcus warderman
erwin rozier natalie doran
brittany byerly brianna
davidson melanie leblanc jennifer the
smithers
philip j smith jr ruby
is dynamite rosie baby darth yoda order
66.
kayla's swimming in the waters just
sj94 the year of pulp
sam castle roe cree a star wars story
sandrine little angel stephen mendoza
got nothing for you to add
matthew men sing meet me and joanna
saint louis
ah russell betty our giant panda king
peter pacheco
no homo but yes homo thomas
ken fairman believes in equality lauren
american horse quite patriotic master
skywalker the jedi bro
jordan jordan topolski hbo miniseries
zach wright absolutely right
oscar as in the insurance company matt
place
sean davis has a great channel josh
barnes loopy gaming that's how i feel
whenever i you know
levitt odell it's a badass seventies
name
nine inch nails is for trent
frederickson i mess it up
jacob gonzalez daniel findura
sounds mexican chase
kelly hales from the north and nash
sonadiki lovely lovely name to close us
off much love to all of you guys thank
you for joining us thank you for being
here and for caring enough
to hear your names come out of our
mouths
you guys rock i love speaking meet
me too